well there's a great example of game
theory in poker that actually is from a
column an economist colleague of mine
named Randy heap
he teaches strategy and actually
sometimes it's teaches with me at Yale
it was I think 2002 in the World
Championship he was playing a fellow
named Thomas Preston who was probably
better known as Amarillo Slim and they
were playing the World Championship
heads up which is a form of I guess
Texas Hold'em it was a forty thousand
euro pot which these days may seem small
but he was a system professor so it was
real money and it turns out the top two
people were slim and my friend heap heap
had a pair of nines and based on the
bedding and the initial hands he was
convinced that slim either had a king or
an ace in his hand but not both
now what happens next is three cards or
the flop or presented and then there's
another round of betting and he had
decided that if either a king or an ace
came out in the flop he was going to
fold because basically the chances of
the pair of kings or aces which is too
high and clearly if slim had a pair of
kings erases he'd stay in he wasn't
going to leave with that kind of a hand
well the cards came out and it was a two
of clubs and the three of diamonds and a
camp Hearts and at that point he sort of
realized damn it I've got five big pot
I'm gonna lose it and his eyes just gave
it away
he he realized that he had not done a
good job hiding his emotions and at the
same time he also realized that slim had
looked into his eyes seeing that
dejection and went all-in at that point
heap said ah slim wasn't betting based
on his cards he was betting based on the
fact that I was giving it and therefore
it means he had the ACE not the king so
he doesn't have the pair and so he went
all-in and won
and basically it was this great analysis
of okay what is he thinking because if
he truly has the pair than what he's
happy about is the cards not about my
digestion my rejection and that wasn't
what Slim was betting on but typically
poker players spent a lot more time
watching the other players than they do
watching their own cards and may also be
why a lot of people were sunglasses